extraction is based on a comic title to
see you Dad and as it turns out the
comic sending is less ambiguous than the
films the climactic extraction scene in
which Tyler's pursuers shoots him when
he falls into a river is adapted from
the comic but while that moment maybe
the last viewer sea of Tyler in the film
The Comic continues and reveals that
Tyler arrives intact to the hospital in
Argentina director Sam Hargrave revealed
in an interview with collider that
Tyler's death was explicit in the film's
original script Netflix even produced a
version of the film in which Tyler's
death is Canon but it's a mixed
reception among test audiences that the
extraction team to decide upon the more
ambiguous conclusion extraction 2 then
was only possible because its
predecessor's original ending was
changed and allowed for the possibility
of Tyler's survival
[Music]